A humble peasant.
A king like this would never fall for me.
I can't hear you!
You gotta cheat for the audience!
A scoundrel and a peasant.
A humble, gorgeous king would never be with me.
Of course he would love a lovely princess like so.
What would I do to have this king love me back?
I'll never know, but I don't think it will happen in this lifetime.
You'll never see me!
Oh, mirror, mirror on the wall,
Who's the fairest peasant of them all?
It's Towers the Peasant.
Towers the Peasant.
I love how hot and sweaty and dirty he gets in the fields.
I watched from my castle tower
and just could not control myself.
But alas,
I cannot tell the world.
How dare he?
I love him,
but he will not return my affections,
let alone the mirror it says
that he may love me,
but I know this not to be true.
I know that only
he loves me.
I know that only he loves me.
I know that I love their friends.
However, I know
he loves me not.
Or he loves me nay.
Potentially. I don't know.
Potentially everybody loves each other, but not me.
That could be it as well.
I only love peasant powers.
My humble king.
But we ask, we all look in this mirror,
who is it that we see
our true love be?
I see him.
The glorious king.
Of course.
Kiss!
Reality is mainly
but the same.
For everyone, there's
always the same reality.
Yeah.
Oh!
Straight!
Oh my!
A strong finish indeed.
Very well.